it's wednesday the 22nd of july
kick this [ __ ] mule lee oh
[ __ ] it all starts [ __ ] today all
right no more [ __ ] excuses this is
the year
of the [ __ ] soldier we're going in
like [ __ ] marines
welcome to church [ __ ]
[Music]
wednesday you little [ __ ] my
beautiful guest today somebody i wanted
to head on for i didn't know he's out
here
my man mr kenny florian kenny and i had
a weird meeting because
i just got into the ufc i was all in
like i thought it was a barbaric sport
and one night i
i turned on this fight there was these
two white guys beating the [ __ ] out of
each other
because the first time it was like
butterbean you can't
you can't look like me and fight there's
no way that that's not even possible
you know so i didn't really like the ufc
joe rogan was my friend
i went to one ufc with him and i just
didn't like it it was in miami
shaq was there and it was like 30 people
in the audience
you can't believe how dead it was and i
was like i'm never coming back to these
things
you know this guy shows up with a karate
suit what kind of [ __ ] is this
i come from aaron banks tournaments in
new york city as a kid right
and also i come to see some guy that's a
doorman at a bingo parlor
he's fighting a [ __ ] priest you know
what i'm saying that's how it was back
yeah it was crazy i don't like this [ __ ]
right
so one night i put it on i see two white
guys beating the [ __ ] out of each other
turns out to be stefan bonner and the
other guy and that was pretty
interesting and then they're telling me
in the car him and eddie
wait joan this and silva shows up i'm
like can he beat up bruce lee if he
could beat him briefly then call me
until that time leave me the [ __ ] alone
anderson's over some [ __ ] brazilian
what do i give a [ __ ]
and next thing you know i'm going
through the channels and it's
anderson silva he's about to fight this
little white dude
it's ufc fight night and he [ __ ]
walls right through him and i'm a fan
i'm like blown the [ __ ] away and now i
started watching
and then you're about to fight and they
did one of those ufc things
of you doing a warm-up and you're like
you know you got to finish it
that's it you got to finish it you got
to finish it i'm getting all hyped at my
house you got to finish it
so at that time i'm looking at mma and
i'm analyzing it towards combat
so that me and ari would go to the
fights we'd eat edibles and we bring
like
2 hours intense and we start gambling
with the people in the audience joe
would get us the best tickets
we would cause pandomania i mean it was
great that's awesome and when i look up
and i see you in the fight and the fight
was [ __ ] boring
and i'm like [ __ ] up and i started
yelling pudding florian
i remember and he's looking at me stop
i'm like pudding florian like there was
like a [ __ ] basketball game like a
mini basketball game
sub substitute put my kid in there he'll
tell you how to do it
put him florian he'll finish it and
florian is like knock it off
you [ __ ] i don't know who the [ __ ] it
was fighting but
after that we became friends that's
hilarious was that was that the heart
was either the hard rock oh
one of the yeah one of the smaller
venues i think
um that's hilarious that was only
remember that i mean one time we were
ralphy to one of the little ones at the
pearl
yeah and somebody got beat up and i'm
not good with blood
right and i had ralphie may 500 pounds
next to me and i had a chick with the
biggest
fakest tits in the world next to me next
to some armenian doctor that was like
90.
he was he had viagra and iv yeah like
he had like a little chinese ready to go
oh yeah this guy
no he didn't know whether it was going
to go he didn't know when it was going
to go she was going to suck a dick
it didn't matter what it was going to
happen so the [ __ ] ring guy wipes off
the guy
and he throws the towel down on the
floor yeah and i just happened to look
at it and it was covered in blood
and i just fainted on the chick's tits
oh thank god the doctor was there
ralphie was laughing his ass off
he put it in my mouth yeah i used to go
to the early one like i that's when i
started going
at the pearl yeah a little place yeah
and then i elevated to the whatever
i remember we spoke and you had a
jiu-jitsu school in boston and you said
yeah maybe you come to boston come by
yeah hello now your brother runs that he
does he runs that we own it together
uh that's in brookline massachusetts and
then uh
yeah i've been that's been open what
since like 2006 i think
wow so yeah when did you get into jiu
jitsu um
i got into jiu jitsu i think 97 i
believe they're 97 or 98
uh high college i was in college exactly
i i uh
you know my brother called me he's like
dude you gotta check out this ufc
it's what we've always talked about they
have guys from all over the world
different martial artists and they all
fight to see who's the best martial
artist and i was like
no way so so who won some jack guy just
knocking everybody out he's like
nah some skinny brazilian guy he kind of
like
takes him down and kind of puts him in
submission holds and they tap out and i
was like
i was so let down i was like what you
know like this isn't i i envisioned john
claude van damme and bloodsport some
dude who's like you know knocking guys
out
and i went and finally saw it and was
just inspired by
it
[Laughter]
thank you for that uh he yeah i was just
inspired by
by that dude uh hoist gracie so that's
that's kind of what
you know kicked off my interest in jiu
jitsu and that's how kind of it all
started now what were we doing before
that any
any karate i was playing soccer at
boston college
i was playing soccer yeah i was playing
soccer you know and went from the uh the
wimpiest sport to
the toughest sport so uh yeah
i was really into soccer and but i did
martial arts throughout you know when i
was a kid and
but as i got more interested into soccer
i just didn't have time and
um just kind of concentrated on soccer
again
uh and then once um you know i got back
into jitsu i was just
just hooked man just hooked how was your
cardio from soccer you must have been
able to vote for how
hell it hell it helped because i you
know i was a midfielder so i was running
all up and down the field so
that that definitely helped having some
kind of competitive thing but
it's way different because you know you
lose in a team sport and you can you
know point
point the finger go that guy did this or
the team screwed up or the goalkeeper
did this or that
or whatever but the one-on-one
competition you had no one to blame but
yourself
and and i hated it but i loved it at the
same time because
you know it it humbled you and uh you
knew exactly what you had to work on so
it
it was like a religious experience doing
martial arts always since i was a kid i
felt like it was a
some kind of spiritual connection that
just everything else didn't matter
nothing else existed except that moment
it was pretty cool was your first
teacher
i had an instructor i went to fred
villarreal's
ca shaolin kempo karate school back in
the day
uh he had you know a bunch of schools
all over the country i guess
and i probably started when i was like 9
or 10 years old
and uh yeah that's how we started how
interesting is campo
it was very interesting to me you know
it's funny because right now in my
school that that i have here in la
um you know i was inspired by
you know my early childhood when i was
doing karate we had
you know a snake on the wall a dragon a
crane and a
tiger and you know you you mimic those
kind of animals and
all that stuff and i thought that was
such a fascinating thing i remember as a
kid just being
just wowed by those animals and you know
what they could do
and how i had to mimic that with my
katas and techniques and things like
that but
back in the day we didn't really know
what was effective because it was all
really theory
you know like the sparring was different
it was point sparring
it was you know was it was just a
different thing but at the time if you
were a black belt karate you know
that was pretty badass you know i really
fell in love with it
as a kid and i'm going back 69
renato la ranger yes his father was my
first karate teacher yeah i didn't know
that
i knew he was an instructor oh my god i
just come from cuba wow
i got beat up and then you know i got
hit in the head with a lunch box
and my mom's like enough is enough wow
i'm taking the karate it was all pretty
much african-american
um it was maybe a couple i was the only
cuban kid a couple puerto ricans
you had a fist on your [ __ ] thing wow
he made you run the streets with your
guy on barefoot in new york city
that's [ __ ] crazy that's amazing and
your friends would see you
and then when you went to school the
next day like hey mr karate man come on
over here
right it was a different [ __ ] world
wow i really got into it i really
liked the discipline yeah it made you
fold your ghee
you had to put the belt down in a
certain way and carry it yes
with your belt i mean he hit you with a
stick
how how old are you back then i was just
five maybe six
days the whole thing that's so cool and
then i would just go on the weekends
when i went to catholic school and then
once i got out of the catholic school in
the fifth grade
i went to gush and ru karate yep but
the best thing about my neighborhood was
north bergen was that
there was a kid that went to fuji pai
kung fu
there was a kid that went to richard
boze aikido
there was another guy that went to a
judo down
on 7th street so is his kid mario diaz
he was a chinese cuban kid
his father was a doctor not diaz like my
last name d-i-e-z
he was cuban chinese and he brought a
lot of kung fu to the table
his father let us take over the basement
we were 12.
yeah we we used to go our whole life was
putting money together to put equipment
so i had a newspaper wrap
you had a route you worked at your
father's liquor store
and our goal was every week to chip in
and buy something different
so on saturdays it was chinatown and
honda
honda was a martial arts store we go
there and geek out wow
like wow someday i'm going to have that
maki
whatever the [ __ ] you had a whole yeah
the board were you a little boy yeah
yeah
we'd do that then we went to chinatown
and bought all the stuff for the iron
palm technique
that's something right you put the mushu
sauce on your hands and
and you know the iron palm and then we
would so each of us were like
no mats no no we weren't [ __ ]
we did throws you landed on the floor
that's just how life went
martin perez his father was batista's
driver in cuba
he's still my friend on facebook he was
the judo doc
he was good so he would come in at night
and teach his masaki we would slam
each other so then after every night
somebody had something that's so
cool you guys were all cross training
before crosstalk that was the thing
yeah so the fuji pie kung fu guy taught
us
the most beautifulest forms you ever saw
in your life you know all this [ __ ]
you know with your hands and the whole
thing and balance
and we'd hold what was that called not
the crane the crane stand
peacock
the crane and then the end of the night
it was just like a jiu jitsu class
now it's time to see what you got wow
and we would spa
and it started out you know because we
were all braced on the point system
the point system was from the neck to
the stomach that's it
anything else you got disqualified for
did you wear helmets and stuff or no
no this is jersey there's no helmets
that's why i quit hockey because they
played street hockey with no helmet
and the first day i went somebody's head
went through a plate glass window on
this oh my god
that's not for me dog this was different
this was plaster walls anybody could go
to
a wall right i could go through a once a
week so i'm 57
that [ __ ] wall like when his father
finally came down a year later one day
he was like
what the [ __ ] happened to my basement we
had punched the walls
heads had been gone through walls there
was blood on the walls
like i said we would sit you would do
your homework
you would go to your own martial arts
school do your homework and then we
would bamboozle our mothers like
i gotta go to lee's because we're gonna
study on that algebra exam okay
all of us we sneak the [ __ ] ghee you
snuck the key in your book bag
or you threw it out in the daytime you
put in the garbage and then you went out
and
took it and we would fight to the death
until 10 o'clock
and then talk for a half hour you know
and that was what we did as kids
we never not one of us ever got into a
fist fight we loved each other right
the highest belt guy was a kid named
something cologne
i have never seen him again his whole
living room was filled with six foot
trophies remember
in those days trophies his whole living
room glenn colon
puerto rican kid he was like in those
days
he was like the chuck liddell of hudson
county he could go into any
martial arts school not bay and they
enjoyed him coming in
because and he was still like a white
belt
in tang tsudo he was a purple belt in
this he was a black
he went to a different school every day
it was crazy
you know i feel like they had good
action movies back in the day but
a lot of the best action movies for me
were martial arts movies so i think
that had such a big influence i think in
a lot of our lives you know i
speak for myself you know just watching
the chuck norris movies and of course
the bruce lee movies and
all those things at you know uh kung fu
theater on the weekends
all that stuff just had like such an
impact
on me growing up that i don't know the
the coolest guy the toughest guy in the
room was that martial artist and
i i wanted to learn that i think i think
i don't know great growing up with some
fear too
and wanted to know how to defend myself
my dad also was a black belt in judo he
wanted us all to kind of learn martial
arts
um i i always felt a special connection
to it and loved watching martial arts
movies i loved
like i watched eddie's thing yeah yeah
at night the little tournament he had
oh yeah yeah the jitsu people tortured
them and i thought it was great
i thought it was great to add something
different to jiu-jitsu yeah
you know so i love watching jiu-jitsu
you know
but i also know sometimes it's brutal to
watch
it it will put you to sleep let's see i
could watch hajo all day long right
that's some
i'm his biggest fan i love the mount and
the [ __ ] i love all that [ __ ] how he
does it like
i love watching garcia i love watching
little jiu jitsu
uh moves you know i love everything
about it but when i was growing up there
was no [ __ ] jiu jitsu there was not
and i had a long talk with matt sarah
about this matt sarah
used to have to go from long island all
the way to red bank new jersey on
sundays
like four hours to train for two hours
to drive back
like that's how jiu jitsu was not even
in the game
and absolutely and and uh tournaments
for us back in the day now you know
out here on the west coast there's you
know everyone when the covert thing
isn't going on there's tournaments every
weekend
but uh on the east coast you know and
matt sarah was one of the guys i always
looked up to but
for us we didn't have tournaments every
weekend so if you had a tournament in
bayonne new jersey then guess what you
had to go to bayonne new jersey to test
yourself and see how your [ __ ] works you
know
so it was uh just a different time and
that was like once every three months or
something like that or four months if
you were lucky
and it cost money you had to stay at a
hotel or you had to drive all the way
down there and drive back or
you know i remember like four or five of
us sleeping in one hotel room back in
the day
sharing some little tiny car that we had
to drive all the way from boston just to
compete in this tournament
so we spent you know maybe a couple
hundred dollars just to get a little
medal and people are like kenny why
don't you compete more like i don't have
the money to go out and test myself all
the time you know we didn't
have that opportunity so it it's it's a
totally different time now and
now you say jiu jitsu or brazilian jutsu
and people know what you're saying for
the most part people know what you're
talking about back in the day like
what's brazilian jiu jitsu what is that
the capoeira
no one you know what the hell i'm
talking about right they were like
things from a different world
yeah like when you looked at black belt
magazine and you looked at the books you
could buy
like that wing chun kung fu and all that
stuff yeah and that was like
what the [ __ ] is that yeah that's a
french kicking stuff exactly
like that you know jiu jitsu is the same
way it was like this thing that was
so [ __ ] far away you know like i was
into the black belt magazine
i competed once a month
in those days i competed all me
when i was in the sixth grade i think it
was twice a month i went to a
competition that's awesome
every saturday we did something martial
art based
you went to class you got dressed after
class there was no pot smoke and these
guys were all geeks
we would [ __ ] our world was to go to
chinatown
buy some bruce lee paraphernalia and
then come back from the city
lie to your parents and go catch a kung
fu movie
there was one video one movie theater
that just specialized in kung fu movies
horrible ones
right like after bruce lee died
everybody would became bruce
exactly all the different spellings yeah
yeah
i would leave that cry in the movie like
you [ __ ] lied to me
because they they made all these movies
and they would just put one picture of
bruce lee in it
and bruce lee bruce lee to the scene
bruce lie
it was like i remember this everybody
got bamboozled
the chinese people were [ __ ] way
before this [ __ ] corona virus
they bamboozled us with this [ __ ]
bruce lee thing and then
they started making movies bruce lye
bruce i still remember
corrado the hong kong cat he was
supposed to replace bruce lee he had new
chunks
plumber's copper on the [ __ ] damn and
his mother with corrado the hunk i can't
even find it on youtube
that's so funny i remember that back in
the day because that's what they they
would hook you be like starring bruce
lee with a different spelling related i
remember
you know i was born in 76 i think uh
bruce lee died what 63. oh 73 okay sorry
uh and in fact it's coming up yeah it's
coming up july 31st
yeah something like i think the movie
got released tomorrow yeah
yeah and and then uh he is 73 yeah
and i remember when as i was older and
my brothers are like yeah bruce lee's
dead i said
what i remember as crying as a kid like
not knowing that
i thought i
yeah and you were born under 20. sorry
jesus christ you're the kiss of death
we also went to the moon he wanted a bet
[ __ ]
mazda dial last week drive to mazda 1000
i couldn't even bet the fight after that
just know the odds were decent but yeah
those
tough style matches knowing that he will
like short notice
made me not like the fight he's mush
forget it
is he bad luck oh if he walks into a
casino
[Laughter]
it's your fault i feel like you rubbed
off on me
i was wondering are there more women
doing
martial arts now back compared to what
you guys were doing oh yeah yeah
many more yeah yeah dave was not even
there was
one girl and she was like really ugly
and
they combed the hair a certain way and
she would come into the class back then
i don't remember no girl yeah back in
the day is
very unusual very unusual yeah there was
angela mao ying
she was like the pioneer for women she's
the chicken into the dragon
she was a real taekwondo chick and she's
the one that does the spinning
back kicks that kills herself yeah and
then to the dragon yeah it was the
biggest chick oh [ __ ]
that was like the biggest asian
superstar of
and i don't know they tried to develop
other ones it's really funny you said
this though because
i want to let the people know that
listen to this just in case
they [ __ ] forgot because i [ __ ]
didn't when i was watching that 30 for
30 with bruce lee yeah
and they showed scenes from returning a
dragon thank god i made a mental note
because i reminded me
to go back and look into deep chuck
norris movies the octagon
there's another one his first three or
four movies
chuck norris was not [ __ ] around guys
i want you to know that
we have written him off because you see
him with a wig and [ __ ] now yeah
and you're selling something he's
selling mayonnaise don't ever get
confused
with who the [ __ ] chuck was a badass
yeah chuck can you read me his first
like
i know there was there was the missing
in actions but he did something before
that
yeah it was before that um you know the
octagon
um was the one like uh
four something some when he was like a
cop who had to like track down a
kickboxer or some [ __ ]
uh he did like three of them in the
beginning you know from the beginning
yeah um the
the wrecking crew the way of the dragon
way the dragon that was good
that was good the student teachers
slaughter in san francisco
breaker breaker a good guy where
wait that was you guys were black yes
good guys wear black a force of one
that's four so one that's the one
the octagon that's a good one an eye for
an eye an eye for an eye
i like island rage that one is benzamor
and then
his his favorite movie that i really got
into was code of silence
nobody saw that you remember it no 83 85
85 dennis farina and that's why i get
mad at steven seagal because he stole
the [ __ ] pool hall scene from [ __ ]
chuck norris [ __ ]
in that code of silence that's why every
time i see steven seagal
yes the colombians yes
yeah of course yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] he put it in the sock or
whatever yeah
beat the [ __ ] he went over there beat
the [ __ ] out of people with this sock
yeah
chuck norris you see him now you're like
who's this [ __ ] old punk [ __ ]
[ __ ] you better recognize he used to
train with bruce lee
daniel santo that guy made some and i'm
telling you if you haven't been into
chuckle norris
watch any of those movies that scene
with bruce lee was one of the coolest
[ __ ] things because bruce lee he was
so ahead of his time first of all but
the fact that you know he actually so in
the scene he's doing he's
basically trying to mimic or doing the
same style of chuck norris
and it's not working chuck norris is
beating the hell out of him during the
fight
and then he realizes he's like i i'm i'm
fighting in patterns and i'm fighting in
this like
you know same way every single time and
he started mixing things up he loosened
up
and you know went into his bruce lee
mode started utilizing his footwork and
started
you know breaking up the patterns and he
started beating the hell out of chuck
norris but
everything for bruce lee was a method of
not only you know
entertaining with his movies but also
giving a martial arts lesson
of not just following these patterns or
you know doing what the other guy is
doing but doing something unique
and different and um the guy was a
genius
is just amazing it really is
set it was sad for us as kids like that
was remember i lost
you guys don't know what i went through
i lost roberto clemente first
right and then bruce lee i'm about this
when i when i was 10 i was about to
shoot a [ __ ]
clemente died in 72. except new year's
eve
wow so you opened up 73 with clementine
diet
how the [ __ ] is this gonna work and it
was a plane crash right yeah
he went not send money like we do today
right he was going to send money he was
going there yeah
he was going there he wouldn't let manny
sing he and go
right there that's beautiful look at the
angel wings
beautiful beautiful [ __ ] picture but
we started 73
with clemente dying like waking up wow
like what
how could he [ __ ] die this guy just
broke the [ __ ] record
that he broke into chase stadium my mom
was at the game [ __ ]
tremendous unbelievable and then [ __ ]
that [ __ ] goes
then along the way [ __ ] freddie the
prince went
and we were really cracked whatever his
name is freddy prince
yeah freddie prince look i cried think
about it wow [ __ ]
yeah we were talking about sports before
you didn't know that i had
i had a deep joke for people who don't
know
joey diaz is a damn encyclopedia when it
comes to sports from
football to baseball like everything old
school like you were talking about
like college players before they were
like you knew what
i didn't know now i don't know i knew
that zeon williamson wasn't gonna last
in the bubble
i called that last week a millionaire's
got to get his dick sucked when you're
20.
you ain't no [ __ ] ain't about bubbles
right [ __ ] that
[ __ ] he's not making the playoffs so he
doesn't care at all
no he's not he's not he's done he's not
come back but
when i was a kid that was my connection
to the america yeah
i wanted to be nothing but an american
right okay so
i had a connection with uh cubans
playing baseball tony perez
sure and the cincinnati reds he grew up
with my father in cuba that was my
end to baseball so i watch baseball
i can i love to tell you yes the
cincinnati reds were my favorite team to
watch
but i'm not that type of shallow person
as a kid yeah i can't just put on a red
shirt
i can't do it i i enjoyed watching the
red sox
the red sox were doing something in the
american league that was awesome also
yeah and the mets were doing that thing
and the cubbies were doing that i was
never really all in like that
like i never understood the ultimate
super fan
because i told you earlier i was living
in jersey and i watched andre tippett
because he was such a badass linebacker
that's how i wanted to play the game
right so it didn't matter colors and
uniforms didn't really matter
i was kind of the same way i wonder you
know both my parents are from peru so
i think it was a weird thing like what
where again i was the only you know
hispanic in
in my town you know growing up or
whatever and i felt
you know it was awesome to support the
home team i definitely was you know grew
up a patriots fan and a celtics fan
um wasn't into baseball so much as a kid
but
um yeah i i enjoyed watching just people
at their best whether it's you know
montana and the 49ers or whatever it was
i you know i just enjoyed watching good
sports uh
so that's my first question to you when
you came in here was do you like sports
because today
i was thinking about it i was walking
into the bathroom i was moving a
kettlebell i put my i went for a bike
ride
yeah and i go i don't even
i don't even give a [ __ ] 72 players get
tested or they come back positive i
don't want to watch
i can't even imagine like in my
old man world never mind when i was a
kid
if i was 15 and [ __ ]
what's his name left i'm ready oh i'd
hunt him down
i'd hunt him down i'd hunt that
[ __ ] down yeah i almost hunted
down julius irving when he left the net
but he went to the sixes and i was close
enough right
he didn't offend me that much i wasn't
that offended
because i could deal with philadelphia
at the time they had a
they had a great football team you know
yeah and i like the hockey team so i can
live i grew up
also watching hockey sure okay i don't
watch it anymore it was too much
information you can't keep up on
everything and once i bet hockey and
lost i was like that's it
hockey's too hard to bet you got to give
three rings i don't know yeah it's too
tough
but when you become a degenerate gambler
you bet hockey and you get your ear
bit off three [ __ ] times and then
yeah you're not gonna go and then you go
the best thing is to go to a ranger
island the game and bet it
that's when you see violence that's real
not today not today that
they just go they pay and they sit there
like [ __ ] steps
but when i was a kid doug people would
get hit
i went listen you sound like you miss it
i still
how can you not miss being a kid and
going to
yankee bat day when the red sox are in
town
just waiting for a bat to get thrown
you're just praying because you know
me and my friends would sit there third
inning i got a dollar on the fourth
inning i got a dollar on the fifth
we're cheering on the inning because you
know at one point
you're gonna see one of those little
bats fly through the [ __ ] hand we
were kids it was back day
how can you make back day in the yankees
when the red sox comes to town can't you
make it like when the [ __ ]
astros come to town or something like
that you got to do it when the red sox
comes to town you instigating
[ __ ]
it used to piss me off like put the bat
down stop with the [ __ ] bat
because everybody would get hit with a
[ __ ] dad at those games oh my god
i've played it on here before so i won't
do it again but my favorite ever clip
is the red sox yankees game at fenway
and a red sox fan
throws a slice of pizza at a yankee fan
hits him in the face
on tv and they kill it then me play it
for the entire game
it's the best thing i've ever seen it's
crazy like pete
if you were a yankees hat you know
at a boston bar like you're going to get
you're either going to get in a fight
you're definitely going to get harassed
at the very least like it's it's crazy
like
but it it's different sports are
different right now
i don't know if it's just because of the
the big business and the big money that
kind of changed everything or whether it
was like
just being nostalgic because you were a
kid but it definitely has a different
feel
now i feel like the new sports or the
new thing is like
you know the thing to argue about is
politics politics is the new sport in
this country almost you know but
um it it definitely feels different
i don't know um than it was when we were
younger i don't know
you know you grow up and you don't have
you lose time yeah as you grow up you
lose time you lose time with the things
that
i i can't see me being 45 with a jersey
young on sundays before my buddies over
there yelling and screaming
i can't do that to myself sure i can't
do that my wife you know
yeah but i had a lot i had a friend in
boulder i was from buffalo
and every saturday night his mother
would overnight him
[ __ ] the beef on wick the wick bread
it's his bread with wick and he would
make the roast beef
you rang his doorbell he would have a
buffalo bill helmet on
he was from buffalo you went in
everybody had buffalo bill albertson
he had four kids he made beef on wick
french fries you know just at wings
buffalo wings
it was an event i loved it it was like
but like he
he was a real [ __ ] fan yeah he was
missing an eye
his brother was a rock in his eye he bit
his
brother's finger off they're from
buffalo they were just grimy guys i
still talk to him i still call him once
a year and say how you doing marty
but i still remember being in this house
from buffalo was to the top of that game
and he had his oldest son was like six
little marty
and he had a brick fireplace and little
marty kept jumping off the brick
fireplace
and i could see that marty scene he was
losing his mind
nick knock it off whatever he would call
it knock it off knock it off knock it
off
i think like in the third [ __ ] thing
the kid fell and sliced his head
oh no he told him to sit there with the
ice on
you're not going to the hospital till
after the game we all had to sit there
watching this kid bleed
he's [ __ ] losing consciousness
but the game was on but the game was no
dvr back in the day
he said i told you i wouldn't take you
to the hospital you're gonna bleed out
before the [ __ ] game ends like
i was around people like that
for me i could never get that crazy
about something right i could enjoy it
watch it but i'm old school i have old
school for like when i go to a baseball
game let's see yellow [ __ ]
dream it's not to sit there like i'm
dead dog this
ain't the [ __ ] opera [ __ ] yeah okay
now you go to a baseball game the last
two years you go to a baseball game
people are scared to say anything yeah
oh really yeah it's like that
last three four ten years it's been
decent you know i went to see clemens
pitch when i was in houston one time you
ever see that [ __ ] pitch live
uh i saw him play for the red sox yes
when i was a kid
did you go watch him i saw him live yes
did you see the intimidation that he
would he was a beast
he was a beast big dude and man could he
throw that ball
and he would walk towards you and
eyeball you and [ __ ]
[ __ ] keep his eye on you as the
battle just watch you and
throw the ball up and make faces and do
it's such an amazing
i think that's what's really killing
people right now too
a big chunk of it is there's no baseball
listen baseball is american
we're on a time clock our bodies are on
a time clock
even if you're not a dodger fan even if
you're not a red sox fan
it's not bad to watch an inning of
something once in a while
you know yeah i agree i think that's you
know so much of our
you know happiness and uh releasing our
frustrations is watching sports and we
can't really do that you know ufc is the
only thing in town really
i mean espn's showing corn hole and [ __ ]
you're like what the hell is going on
[ __ ] espn showing the eagles concert
that's when you know are bad i put on
espn there's a band on stage
you know what's going on what the [ __ ]
is this
what happened what happened with me was
there's been so much fighting and
yelling
every time you put the tv on somebody's
getting arrested somebody's getting
handcuffed
and one night a man the nunes was
fighting that fight
and i i didn't like i wanted to get i
wanted to do something
yeah but i loved the alex uh
chaturay fight you know alex caceres oh
yeah when he was fighting a white kid it
was the first week of black lives matter
ain't no white guy winning this week not
this week you know what i'm saying
you're going in there you're gonna throw
that you're talking about the last one
chase hooper yeah and i love hoopa yeah
that's why i was going to be a tesla
right like
this is too much of a time yeah this is
a lock this is
there's no reason even better man than
knew that right and i remember like my
wife goes do you want to order the main
card and i go for what i really want
money
and i don't want to see any fighting
yeah like i've seen enough fighting
it was like the week before the riots
right and we're watching punching and
people getting sure
and i'm like you know what even like
wednesday's fight last week i passed on
come out i don't even know the [ __ ] foot
i don't know what to [ __ ] for it
right i did watch uh the thing with
rogan that was interesting yeah
the last card but there was a couple
cards that i'm like i don't even want to
watch there's too much fighting going on
this week there's too much it's crazy
whether you're going on
you know social media already it's
everyone's [ __ ] pointing fingers and
fighting with each other
it's it's ridiculous digging up scabs
yeah
digging up scabs i saw something today
latinos are mad now because it's like
everybody's angry everybody wants a
piece or something i i i had to stop
with the internet i i cut it down yeah
fifty percent
sixty percent you gotta you're gonna
lose your mind
what happens is i saw something last
week that was so disturbing
somebody wrote on twitter i can't wait
to the unemployment benefits dry out
you know i'll run off so all you [ __ ]
squats
spongebob dry up like a sponge or
something i'm like
who would write that what type of person
wants to see somebody lose 2 400
a month right now in the middle of this
[ __ ] pandemic
but that's the evil that's going on
right now in people's hearts
it's coming out and it's not their fault
it's just that we're so
vulnerable we're so left open right now
we're getting bad information we're
getting bad information
you know the air is bad the energy is
bad
and for me like i said i've cut i go on
there in the mornings i say what i've
got to say and i get the [ __ ] off there
because
you always see something that's going to
make you go what the [ __ ] do it
this is entertainment social media is to
connect
with friends
yeah it's a battleground now and i've
met it's insane
i have great friends that i don't know
what their face looks like
but we have great conversations on the
internet sure
and i really appreciate that but the
rest of it is
stuff you know you know the other day i
read the comments about us that
they should do the set wha why don't you
go watch
take a bat like redo the set it was just
people trying to start
problems and you're like this is what
it's like and i get it i'm not even mad
at them they're out of work
they're not getting what they used to
the girlfriend don't want to suck up
that dick no more she's scared of
anxiety
you know the world's upside down so
where are you going to go posture
you can't hit somebody the gym is closed
you can't lift weights
yeah who's the easy what's the lowest
hanging vine
social media i'd go on social media and
call anybody anything i want
and say without repercussions without
repercussions yeah yeah
facebook will cancel me for a week big
deal but i could go into somebody's dm
right and call them a [ __ ] i
hate
you [ __ ] you i mean that's unheard of
who raised you
well that's why they create like they
call them trolls
is they don't care if their account gets
taken down they'll just make another
they just make another one but again
who's at home doing this
what kind of person sits there making
faith putting all this thought
into bad when you can be putting all
this thought
into something good people have nothing
going on right now i i think you know
you're definitely right
people are really pissed off you know
based on the situation
but also you know i think we get caught
up in living in this virtual world
thinking that it's real you know and
you're at home you got nothing going on
you got no job you're pissed off about
your life
and you can go on anonymously and rip
different things apart rip people apart
rip organizations apart and
it's interesting because you know if i
am a foreign actor
or another uh you know country and i
want to see the demise of the united
states
and i wanted to rip them apart from the
inside out that's the best way
you want to blow something up is you do
it from the inside out
and you get them to be as divisive as
possible and i i think that
we are doing this to ourselves you know
just based on the technology and
you know how angry people are but i do
think that people are
you know other you know countries like
china and russia and other different
things you know
i'm not getting a conspiracy theory this
is just what happens but
if i poke you guys enough and i go oh
he's talking [ __ ] about you and he's
talking [ __ ] about you
you guys are gonna start to hate each
other and that's what's going on it's
just like
people are poking everybody and they're
getting these very sensitive subjects
and they're ripping the country apart
instead of like
understanding that we are one country
and we're trying to what makes this
country great is the fact that we do
have many different people
you know in one spot which is very
unique to places like europe that are
essentially obviously they they have you
know
a lot of different immigrants that are
making that that country you know uh
great and unique and special but people
are trying to
make things worse in this country i have
no doubt about it and
and it's scary and it's it's tough
because we we forgot that
we're all trying to move in the same
direction and you know this political
thing
everything is being politicized why
because like what you were talking about
the information
everyone's getting different information
i can get any
subject and if you look it up on the
internet you can validate what you might
think
and you get competing information and no
one knows
what the [ __ ] is going on like if i
asked you guys what's going on with
covid right now
and and how it's spread and what's going
on there's so much different information
that we're getting of how you get it and
what's going on
is the numbers going up down left right
i
it's it's insane i don't know it's just
[Laughter]
and the worst part for me is neither
whatever side you're on
they're just so convinced that they're
right right with with no back with no
background information from anybody yes
but they're just like
i'm right i'm you can't change my mind a
bit
i saw a youtube video or because i think
this way
it has to be this way i mean no no one's
using their mind
no one's using their brains anymore it's
just like
i don't know they'd rather just join up
on a team join up on a side and and
fight the other guy and talk [ __ ] i
don't
i don't know i'm not mad at them right i
really can let you know through my heart
that i'm not mad at people's actions you
know
i understand the frustration the
uncertainty
sure you know about the future what's
going to happen what are we going back
to work and we're not going back to work
how am i going to feed my kids that's a
lot of [ __ ] questions for somebody
you know so i look at it from the other
angle too i look at these people and go
what's making them
do that i say a prayer for them you
light a candle
whatever you can i want to know what's
making them
say that what's making me
[ __ ] you know you know everything i
do i question that
sure you know this has been uh this has
made people think
and thinking scared they tell you don't
think if you're a man don't think
because there's a scan of the jesus out
of you
right now we've given people time to
think
people haven't thought this much since
the summer before college
this is the first time remember you get
thrown into college you're into the
world
right you're into the world studies you
get a piece of ass
next thing you know you get married you
pick a major she's a [ __ ] this she's
graduating
you're going to europe with her family
you get a job on wall street she gets a
job
you got a dog named boo right and also
one day you're like what the [ __ ] how
did i get here
you're back to that talking head song
and that's the first time you really
think you're like what the [ __ ] just
happened
i just wanted to go to school to be a
penguin and smoke dope and now i'm
married i got a kid
i got a nut every month i got to make a
certain amount of money what the [ __ ] is
this
what have i done now my wife wants to go
to israel to touch the wall that's
another ag's
she doesn't even speak [ __ ] israeli
what you know that's what happens to
people
and this is what's happening right now
it gave people
a time to think do i really want to do
jiu jitsu anymore right i was doing it
because i was dating that girl and i was
a president
she dumped me do i really need to drop
dump the 180 anymore
right you know do i want to act anymore
you know i'm sure there's a lot of
fighters that are reconsidering their
careers
[ __ ] the [ __ ] knockouts what they
could do to you all right i think i'm
not covered what if i bring it back to
my family
what if i bring it back to my teammates
in my corner people are thinking right
now
and that's the scariest part of this
i've got into foxholes
right now i know that it's scary
and i've gotten caught up into mental
foxholes throughout this thing
i can't imagine somebody who doesn't see
it coming
absolutely and when they don't have
the tools or the background to be able
to
put into context and and believe in
themselves
too because you know and that's what i
think is is the most special thing about
martial arts more than anything else is
that
you'll learn about yourself and you
learn about how to deal with adversity
and
and you find that inner strength in
yourself you know the best thing i did
was the last 10 years
besides having my daughter it wasn't
the comedy it wasn't the theaters it
wasn't the specials
you know what really jolted me joining
jiu jitsu i love it
you know what happened it let me know
and let me know
how bad of shape i really wasn't
i knew i was fat but i didn't know
because the mental aspect came in sure i
saw my mental weakness
and that could not happen i was about to
have a family
i was i wanted to take my career to the
next level how can i have this mental
weakness
i couldn't have people get on top once
you mounted me
i had a heart attack are you [ __ ]
crazy right
that's what half of jiu jitsu is you
know how many times i had to run out the
first week out of jiu jitsu
with my guillaume take my belt off and
take my dick out on the street and piss
because of the stress like the anxiety
how many times i had to go inside and
take my g
off because i made the mistake like my
fourth jiu jitsu class to take an edible
who's that genius tell me who does that
when that [ __ ] mounted me he was
like a purple belt he could fly me like
a [ __ ]
like an islander and i was like a
[ __ ] palm tree he had me in like a
bow tie
with my arm out and i'm tapping not
because he was hurting me i had a tap
from the anxiety yeah
i basically had to get up and run to the
door i started at vmac
i didn't want anybody to know no eddie i
didn't want anybody to know
i just knew i wanted to try it and that
changed my whole life
so i got my nose fixed i started
breathing out of my nose
i haven't rolled since i tore my
uh hamstring but before that i slowed
down
i stopped going to albertos because
albertos was too fast for me
great guy yes great teacher great school
got everything available to you but the
jiu jitsu was too fast for me
i needed i needed old man jiu jitsu
right i need
50 year old jiu jitsu clothes god
scissor sweet
you know [ __ ] no that's the way it
should be
jiu jitsu should be that way jiu jitsu
was developed it's supposed to be the
soft art you know
and in general i feel like we're also
moving away from that in a lot of ways
unfortunately you know it was supposed
to be
you know a style that you could do
smoothly
you know with technique that the
technique could lead the way you don't
have to be fast you don't have to be
strong
you know you know and i think jiu-jitsu
is moving in a different direction now
because there's so much of the sportive
aspect of it that i think we're losing
connection with what jiu jitsu really
does and what it
what it should do um but you know like
you said i think
on the mat there is no running away from
yourself there is no
you know pretending that you're good at
what you do you're going to find out and
and there's always someone i don't care
what level you're at there's always
someone that's better than you
at least in one or two aspects of the
game and
you'll find out and and it's humbling
and it's always
you know looking at yourself and i don't
i feel like we don't have that there's
no other things that really can keep us
in check
you know there's a lot of other things
you know there's other things we can do
but
jiu jitsu it connects that mind body and
spirit where
you know you're going to find out
exactly what you need to work on on that
mat that day
like they're it's crazy it's crazy it is
like for me the physical was the obvious
but for me it was the mental i started
doing kettlebells to work on my
breathing
everything i did was around jiu jitsu
but guess what
guess what bro you know what if that car
i drive right now
needs an oil change i'm not mechanically
inclined
if that car gets a flat tire i'll
probably trade it in
i'm one of those guys because i'm not
mechanically inclined right i never
wrestled in high school
i didn't my friends wrestled and i knew
the lingo you know
i knew the lingo to lifting sure i just
did steroids i knew all that lingo
uh jiu-jitsu was something that i
started hanging out with eddie and joe
and they were passionate about and i
went to watch them do it and it wasn't
for me it was two guys hugging
i like you guys but the suspect all
right
and then i started watching the ufc and
i saw the beauty of it right
and then i eliminated the ufc and just
started watching
jiu-jitsu videos and i [ __ ] loved
hajjah
there's just a lot of guys i became fans
of your videos
it was just a lot but i like simple [ __ ]
right
i like hodges style well you know me too
pass your guard
you know [ __ ] lapel [ __ ] you know he
just mounts you
and then gets you the [ __ ] little
choke that's all i wanted to do
now they're doing baron bolos wrapping
the gear right around the world
and all this crap what i'm waiting to do
is i'm waiting for this coronavirus to
disappear
because this is what i was doing i took
this advice from uh the drummer of
poison
he trains at uh street sports oh okay
yeah
yeah and he told me he goes there came a
day from me
where he goes i couldn't keep up with he
goes when i had my black belt
because i just couldn't keep up with
purple belts 28 year old purple
it's a different game so he goes i go to
hanato and i get privates
and he goes he beats the [ __ ] out of me
once a week or twice a week
and he goes down there and he goes that
you know i like the class aspect though
sure see i grew up
i don't like and i i know you're going
to hate me to say this but
i don't like like you have clients and
they have
their hollywood clients and they have
money to burn
so they do private classes and that's
all great yeah
but i don't think by doing i like a
private once a month
to say kenny can we work on this scissor
suite
what what is wrong with this scissors
sweep me and you work on it we roll a
little bit yes
you let me that's what i like yes if
you're not going to go to a class
that's what for me was part of it
it's just like stand up joshua sat there
and we talked about stand-up
now when i went to seattle there's a
list on monday nights and wednesdays and
you start at number one
and through time you work up to number
three then number seven
and guess what now you're closing the
show you're number 16.
i you know what i like about martial
arts that you start in the back as a fat
[ __ ]
that's the truth you barely get through
the warm-ups
you know and you just keep going back
and you keep going back and also
somebody befriends you
and you start talking to this guy you
start talking to that guy
and now before nobody there was never a
martial art and i told you my story
early on
about martial arts but one thing i miss
about jiu jitsu
is the friendship is after kenny
beats the [ __ ] out of me and chokes me
he'll go hey
don't go nowhere i got a big man choke
for you
you you yeah like he'll tell you you're
wasting your time
like after these guys beat you up
they're like
come on try this get my arm go there see
you don't have to step like this
right that's what i really miss about
jiu-jitsu well i'll say this when things
calm down number one
i want to offer my services any time and
i've already told you
i've already told you any time you want
to train one-on-one i i don't care i'm
not gonna charge
just let's train one-on-one i hope i can
help you if i do i i'd feel really good
about it because
i love you and i'd love to to help you
out with with your jiu jitsu when things
get normal again
but i think that you have a unique
position though you've lived a lot of
life and you understand
the importance of adversity and battling
back from different things and looking
into yourself and
you know stand up one of the hardest
things you could do i think you know i
i don't understand it
mcqueen and not that i'm a movie star
but with steve mcqueen and bruce lee
bruce lee always wanted what steve
mcqueen had right steve mcqueen always
wanted what should
we have you know i would love my biggest
regrets i'm not going into the army
i would have loved to fall for my
country shoot a couple [ __ ]
immigrants
just to prove you're an american shoot a
couple people in the head
right to really wear the flag like yeah
that's right and defensively
i defended my goodness i've never heard
that as a regret before
and shooting in the truth it's the truth
you know i should have been down in
beirut throwing [ __ ] bombs
i regret not joining karate at 25
with jiu jitsu and making it like a like
a light like i should have looked at it
as this is what i'm going to do until
i'm 60. after college i was either doing
one or two things for whatever reason i
just felt a calling
to a warrior lifestyle was either going
to be martial arts or was going to be
the military it was one of those two
things that's what i
said i felt the calling for i felt like
i needed to do something and face some
fears
i really wanted to join the military
because that's what my mother wanted me
to do that was her all-time
you know you come here you bring your
child to this country to grow up
the least you could do is send them to
donate it
like that's because i'm sending you i'm
just sending you because
they took us in so she always felt that
i
made the appointment but i didn't show
up because it was a blood test involved
and i had done coke the night before
there's no reason might have been tough
he's not going to take me you know what
i'm saying
oh that's amazing so that's one thing
that i do miss
and i do i know that i don't i'm
thinking about moving
but everything's up in the air right now
we're just thinking
i'd like this colby to be over because
i'm riding the bike now
and i've been riding it for an hour and
now i've got talking jiu-jitsu
on the r on the road yeah okay [ __ ] you
yeah
the little one you know what happened
you know i travel
and when i travel i love
i mean it wouldn't be a good show
because i'm not good at it
if i was a black belt in jiu jitsu i
would finance my own
i would bring a camera guy on the road
go do comedy and go to
a jiu jitsu school on friday and train
with a teacher and go to a different jiu
jitsu school on saturday and put them on
tape and put them on youtube right
through the whole experience like
anthony bourdain only with jiu jitsu
that'd be food why can't you do it you
should do it anyway
because i'm not traveling
number one well yeah right this is
[ __ ] cold
uh after this it's gonna be really tough
for traveling jiu jitsu people
after this it's gonna be very hard for
me to fly in from france and say right
hi mr florida
i'd like to come in and train listen get
your covered germs out of my [ __ ]
building all right
i just reopened and you want to come in
here and breathe on people with
fifi breath and [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here with your cheese
fifi yeah whatever the [ __ ] you know
it's not gonna be
that's not gonna that's what jiu jitsu
is about it's about traveling going to
other schools and getting your ass
kicked at another school
but what's this covet thing it's not
going to be like
you came in from australia you can't
come in here that's
i don't love you but i got i got to know
where the [ __ ] you coming from i don't
know if you want to
i don't know if you stopped that warhead
for a cat stick on the way here
it's tough i hope these i hope these
vaccines that they're talking about does
something
i hope that oxford one looks the oxford
exactly that's the one
one looks promising yes i ain't gonna
take it unless it's a pill
right but that's what i found out
yesterday i had made an appointment for
the dentist
and she asked me if i had been in
contact with him i don't know when she
goes
she's a dear friend of mine our
daughter's trained together okay then we
were kickboxing yesterday and i saw
she's just really badass so uh
she told me that i i got the blood test
and she goes
that's not good she goes even the prick
of the finger isn't good that's right
they're just finding out
it's got to be the mouth swab or the
nose i did the
i did the mouth i did the mouth swap did
you which is way easier i didn't do the
yeah yeah and you don't have to do it
all the way in your nose anymore
oh really no you put it in and wait
until it stops it tickles a little bit
but because i see that thing like all
the way up into like
brains i'm like dude nah no i don't
wanna
you ever stick a [ __ ] q-tip in you
you forget it's in there
oh my god i was like a chinese a bomb
next to me
he's gonna hit a gun next to you that
hurts
guy was in there huh you forgot there
was a q-tip
one day i did something like i [ __ ]
had a q-tip in my ear
and the phone rang and i actually put oh
boom
that hurts what else you got going on i
know you got the podcast and john on it
yeah
i got them do that here i do i so i do
that from from my house
i just do uh you know do it in a room in
my house
uh do the anakin flooring podcast been
doing it for what four or five years now
and uh
yeah do it every monday and and uh i've
been
you know i own um school with my buddy
jason hunt
uh meraki brazilian jitsu out in uh i
guess technically brentwood's right on
the brentwood santa monica line
right on santa monica and barrington um
i got a school with my
with my brother in brookline
massachusetts florian martial arts
center and
um just been doing that i've been
teaching i honestly you know the
the favorite thing my favorite thing to
do right now is is teaching and training
jiu jitsu i just love it i'm going to be
doing an instructional
uh hopefully the next couple months when
i could you know things calmed down a
little bit
so i i just been working really hard on
on
on trying to be the best teacher and
best martial artist i could be and
i've never been happier you know i hurt
my back that's why i retired
from the ufc and and um for the for the
first couple years when you know when i
moved here to la
i wasn't able to train i wasn't able to
do a whole lot and i was
i was miserable i was miserable and i
forgot that i was a martial artist you
know like you retired you're like well
i'm not gonna train anymore i'm not i'm
not fighting anymore
i was miserable and i missed it and once
i was physically
able to get back and start training and
you know started
you know uh training with that with ryan
hall who fights in the ufc right now and
he helped me
so much with jitsu and just inspired me
so much and i just like
this is what i got to be doing it has to
be a part of my life otherwise like i
i just don't feel the same not as happy
have you ever considered training a
fighter
i do yeah so i help out ryan and certain
guys at
the gym and stuff like that that we we
have you know maybe not a whole lot of
fighters
most of us most of the guys at my gym
are hobbyists and and guys who
you know compete in jiu jitsu but uh
there's one or two guys that you know
want to compete in
and mma and stuff so i i enjoy helping
them out you know i
i take that very seriously because you
know the repercussions of getting hurt
in a fight
very real so um i i love watching it
love
training it love learning about it and
and and trying to make it better all the
time so i
i it's not open right now we are
closed down just because of the uh you
know did you open it
we did we were open for a little bit
well you know when we were allowed to
and
and uh you know so just kind of waiting
for things to calm down again it's been
really tough man being a being a small
business owner
you just kind of get screwed over and
you were talking about you know
california
maybe leaving stuff like that i i've
been really disheartened by the by the
state and the way that things are run
because you know and i get it
you know we're in this pandemic and it's
very serious it's horrible but
also there's there hasn't been a whole
lot of support i feel like for
for small for small business owners
everything's about the big businesses
that are running this country they
always get
bailed out of something but a lot of the
small business owners the entrepreneurs
who really kind of uh
you know built this country in a lot of
ways are kind of being left behind so
it's
it's been tough you know there's
obviously been loans and different
things that you can apply for which has
been good but
um getting shut down left and right it's
really hard to run a business that way
this second shutdown inspired my mind to
move
because of the recovery factor my age
and i had already been thinking about it
for a while yeah that
it was you know like dean del rey said
we're paying more for gas here
it's crazy so expect the taxes and the
taxes
so you have to look around now for a guy
like me and go what am i doing
how am i planting seeds that are going
to grow
what can i there's no more stand up
listen there's no more standing
there's not going to be any [ __ ]
standard and they're going to keep you
close
until you find a way to open
and know that you could still
do it if even if it takes drilling class
and you put circles on the floor
sure you got nine guys at a time with a
[ __ ] ball what's that brazilian guy
from san diego that has the book with
the drills yeah andre galvan andre
yeah wow yeah i'll drink our valve
i can't put yours together right but i
can drill you to death for an hour sure
i open up both doors
you know there's that it's gonna make
the it's gonna make the owner
a little bit more you guys a little bit
more what's
going on here you know yeah you're
suffering i know cabrini is eating a big
dick i love cabrini yeah he's down there
on wilshire
and [ __ ] la brea or whatever what's
he playing
you know uh john jock is up in tarzana
but his other one in malibu
yeah he's taking a stab and then you
know this is uh
affecting the martial arts community i
mean
forget about i mean karate was holding
on by a string
every time somebody gets an on bond that
you ever see the karate school closes
right or wrong every time somebody shows
up
another karate school closed that's
amazing
every time somebody gets a heel hook
look kevin gaston got hit
right the krav maga school closed on
monday they don't need you no more go
back to israel and use that [ __ ]
you just got to be my you know it's the
truth absolutely
someone's got to make a t-shirt out of
that yes every time something gets
on-board
that goes taekwondo go to any taekwondo
school
it looks like they got covered there's
three guys throwing punches
it's like something of the past it's
like black and white tv
oh [ __ ] anything you want to promote
kenny anything
ah no you know that that's pretty much
it man i i
uh yeah but rocky where's the block come
from you know it's a greek word
uh i was looking for a name for the for
the academy and
uh meraki means putting your soul into
your work to putting putting love into
what you do putting a passion into what
you do and
uh that kind of resonated with me and uh
uh i loved it so it's a greek word for
brazilian jiu jitsu uh you know school
but
uh yeah so you know we we hope to be
you know ready ready to be open we're
we're ready to be open
wait but thank you just gave you
permission here we go
we're gonna we're wrapping circles going
to do a 6 30 drill class
you know everybody's drilling on a
[ __ ] ball there we go that's it and
sprinting and
what's wrong with the hip escape show me
a man who doesn't hip escape how many
[ __ ] hip escapes
do i got to do to become a black boat
nobody can do enough hip escapes
you're 10 pounds overweight start hip
escaping oh man hip escaping back
forth reverse hip escaping on your head
baron bolos i got [ __ ] for you i got for
all you 20 year olds i show up i got a
whip
i'll get you in shape [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] hip escape
back there you go i'll have your hip
escaping down [ __ ] labrador
there's nobody will get on top of you
but that's that's the truth it is you
know i told a bunch of my friends that
are having a hard time ago
you're giving up you're giving up i want
you to propose something to me
right propose something to me that
kenny's my teacher
kenny is there's going to be i have 30
students
i have 10 three-man groups or ten
four-man groups
so kenny's gonna put me with a brown
belt a purple belt a blue belt and a
white belt
we could only be together yeah it's us
four so if
it spreads out of control it's us four
you didn't go to that other school did
you no don't go to kickboxing i'll kick
you in the [ __ ] head those schools
are dirty
i agree so these four people roll
together
they're the only ones that can roll
together for a time that's the way we
had it when we were open
for people it was even less so you just
get one training partner for that day
and that day you know
here's the thing i feel like you know
you're responsible adults be creative
be smart about it this is a real thing
you got to respect it
but also you know use common sense and i
think that's
that's one thing we have to be careful
with is sometimes like we rely on
things to be taken care of way too much
you know do we need to put fencing
around a volcano i mean [ __ ] you fall in
the volcano you're gonna die you know
you
yeah how where do we where do we take
this you know as far as
we have the information people are dying
from this thing it's a serious thing
so be responsible um but also allow
gyms that want to be open if people feel
like hey i'm going to be responsible i'm
going to make sure i'm not hanging out
with other people i'm going to wear the
mask everywhere else
when i go into the gym and make sure
everybody else is doing the same thing
if i just train with that one person
we can do it responsibly you know what's
that
no no no no you can't breathe yeah it'd
be impossible
alberto has these little masks he gave
me one when he came
you put him on your ears it's okay yeah
when i box i wear it
with the other guy okay yeah it's okay i
don't think it's gonna work
you know jiu-jitsu is the complete
opposite of social distancing
it literally is my friend is having a
hard time i thought about paying them
and taking the beginning class at 5 30
because i have nothing but time now
but i also thought about melting
somebody sweating
and one of my sweats goes yeah
i would never forgive myself you know
it's like i told joe
i wouldn't take one of those swabs in
the nose anyway i put coke in my nose
rocks pubic hairs there's been you know
i put so much stuff in my nose i don't
trust the test but
and even
it's gonna be false positive something
you know this throws me off this whole
[ __ ]
uh tested positive for everything i like
it i thought about that i thought about
let me just go to he's got a great 5 30
class you know and i thought about
you know i don't even want to do
stand-up like i am
petrified to do stand-up this petrifies
me
yeah you know but i know i'm clean i
know you're clean i leave the door open
to get some ventilation sure once you
close that door
my heart starts beating i can't have
even last night with sickly
you saw i made him leave the door open
oh yeah gotta have the dog
when i go get blood right i gotta see a
window
a couple of years ago i acted weird and
i didn't know why i acted like that
towards somebody
i got really angry yeah i felt bad the
next day i had a call
and i figured out he put me in a room
with no windows
for 10 hours i went [ __ ] nuts i went
[ __ ] nuts
listen uh what's the website from
meraki's uh marachi
bjj.com and whenever you want to start
over 50 class you let me know and i'll
do everything i can to support you
thank you you know uh cabrinia does it
yes oh that that's awesome i didn't know
that
7 a.m gotcha and it makes sense are you
a morning guy
yes yeah okay but to do a [ __ ]
barambolo at 7 8
your back isn't quite i can't do that oh
my god yeah yeah
no no i'm just saying yeah just
jiu-jitsu at seven o'clock
right it's like i could jump in the pool
at seven if i had i've already done it
yeah a cold pool in boulder oh nice yeah
i used to be part of this master
swimming program
since i am [ __ ] [ __ ] it's snow 12
inches i'll see you five to six
right you know it's one of those places
yeah uh
i ride the bike early now as soon as i
get up now i do what i got to do brush
my teeth
it's great because no one's around
either shoot because it's early you get
it over yeah jiu jitsu is one of those
things that
people over 50 the highest time they get
a heart attack between six a.m and
lunchtime
because you're not sleeping so you know
yeah yeah so it's you even supposed to
you're supposed to take an aspirin
before you go to sleep when you're 50.
yes so when you hit that time zone
you're covered
yes so i don't like doing a lot of i'll
lift it 10 15.
i do heavy lifting during the week twice
but
uh jiu-jitsu a7 is just a little too
real for uncle joe
i i agree uh we we have a seven a.m
class but how many people show it's at
four
yes you know what it's it's grown a
little bit actually it
sometimes it started out that way but we
have some guys who want to work out
before
you know before work so when we weren't
in the kova days we'd sometimes get like
14 16 guys depend you know it wasn't bad
yeah but uh i'm not that guy you know
i'm not a
7 a.m trained jiu jitsu guy i like a
little later in the day i like i like
sleeping but so you do mondays at lunch
time you invited me to that yeah
you always well again any time what time
do you do days so
right now we're close right now we're
close but um
evening classes is all we're doing um
yeah yeah so when we're open it's just
evening just because
nobody's coming no one's really coming
so we don't have the the student base
yet
but uh if you know when things open up
maybe we'll bring back some classes so
doug it was a real pleasure to see you
what what are the next fights
we got fights this weekend darren till
against robert whittaker
so yeah who else is on that car uh who
else
a couple other good fights i think yeah
well that's the main event anyway that's
all like that's a good fight that's a
good fight
yeah whitaker healthy whitaker
supposedly is healthy darren till is
healthy
you know um that should be a great fight
mauricio who uh and shogun who against
rogerio nogueira yep that's right and
then we'll get abe lincoln to fight
george washington
they're a little at the end of their
career yeah this is true yeah
they're definitely doomed versus uh uh
yeah they do them against gustafsson
yeah yeah yeah gustafsson's fighting at
heavyweight for the first time
that's a goal yeah that's a good fight
i'll watch the card yeah yeah it should
be a good card
mr florian it was a real pleasure
pleasure for me thank you so much
yes you know i told people that i put on
my patreon tell you that
last night i saw somebody and i almost
cancelled
and the reason why i didn't cancel was
lee's birthday
and i wanted to do something with him he
was going to stay at home all night i
know him
i told him get the money he tried to lie
to me he's jewish i didn't get the money
i have the money still on me no money i
go
get the 400 you got hitting with the
passport in case there's an earthquake
he forgot he told me so he slipped out
as he was telling me he was denying it
he's like [ __ ]
now he's gonna know i have that money
he's gonna torment me about that money
now i can't get away from him i was i
told him i was going to bring him to a
hooker house
i don't know who says i don't even know
where to find the [ __ ]
i'm 57 years old i don't even know what
the [ __ ] this time
so i don't come on you know and i took
him down we just went to do a podcast in
santa monica just to get out of the
house
yeah but we were in front of the place
where they had like major [ __ ] riots
he was breaking it down for us how they
were if they were all
controlled everything was controlled
they would
come down with the guns it was all then
they would break stuff another van would
come
yeah take [ __ ] out so it's uh it's just
weird that i i wrote today that
the best therapy you could do right now
is to see somebody
and keep social distance but just talk
to them just rap you know
rap even if it's just for an hour when
you get home like last night come fall
asleep i don't know what the [ __ ] you
did last night you know what we did i
ate the same thing i ate the same
[ __ ] edible
i could not sleep for the life of me wow
i was so rushed
up from talking to somebody at eight
o'clock right
you know having a conversation after
eight o'clock that hasn't happened
since march 3rd in my world we went out
i went out one night to rogan's i got
home at 11
30. right that was a big night and then
last night you were on fire last year i
mean to be fair it was about three hours
of you out of ten telling stories and
yelling okay
i couldn't fall asleep
i ate all of them last night by the way
i ate all of them i didn't eat no food
what did i eat for food nothing oh
potato chips
i like like a little bag of did they
send you with the lobster rolls from
whatever
a little bag of potatoes i didn't eat
lunch yesterday i had 10 points left on
weight watchers i'm like
i'm not gonna make anything i just hope
of a peanut butter and jelly but we had
no white bread
you can't eat peanut butter jelly on a
[ __ ] wheat bread she went out with
breakfast
i told him you [ __ ] up my night last
night and then i tried to buy him a
pizza
i go what's the least i could do for him
he loves his crops
crispy okay if you give
lee a piece of [ __ ] or a piece of pizza
he'll take the pair take the pizza and
the crispy crust
yeah he'll tell the girl girl i'll go
home so i knew that was make his night
so we pull up to joe's the little
mexican guy comes out he's like
ah we're close i'm in spanish i'm like
password complain
and he's like no we're close you
[ __ ] i couldn't even
and then i was taking my yum yum donuts
but i didn't want to enable him
and give him a donut that's [ __ ] all
right if i'm going to give him someone's
a nice slice of pizza sure a sicilian
piece but
happy birthday i'm sorry i thought it
was
tuesday so that's what happened this
week
i was thrown off i always went the whole
week thinking your birthday was tuesday
oh i didn't know it was gonna be monday
so you threw me off i didn't have
a chance to buy your card or nothing so
i want to thank
you no i had a blast birthday oh my god
that edible
kicked me oh you're still [ __ ] up oh
yeah
and he wanted me to take more and he's
like okay we have a podcast tomorrow one
so he's like at like 11 o'clock cause
they take another one
what time do you fall asleep i don't
know as soon as you walked in the house
pretty much walked in [ __ ] the lights
were still on where i woke up
good oh that's how you know he gives
edibles they're like i'll just you don't
even know you fall asleep we just wake
up like scared at six
i had no idea i fell asleep i love you
[ __ ] i want to thank kenny
florian
i want to thank my main man the christ
killer happy 32nd birthday to you
i hope you get some of that jew milk out
this week and spread it out
let's get some more jew babies out there
we gotta we're gonna get some more
mexican jews chinese jews you gotta give
you gotta give some flavor to the jewish
giving it out for free whenever they
want oh maybe it's a little puerto rican
chick so you can bring her home mama be
happy
the wig will flip your mom would be
throwing wait for the pork chop gets
fried you know what i'm saying
don't forget if you want the mind of
joey diaz
patreon.com joey diaz a dollar
a dollar a dollar i love you
[ __ ] have a great weekend see
you monday the 27th
tip top magoo nice and early thank you
goodbye
kick this [ __ ] mule league
[Music]
that's